but my first guest up here on the Rich
Eisen show he was on lunch talk live
earlier here on NBCSN but I figured I
want to have him on to to ask my
questions about his questions he put two
dr. Anthony Falchi of the National
Institute of Health the director of the
ni of the National Institute of Allergy
and Infectious Diseases and a key member
of that White House coronavirus task
force was queried by Peter King and his
football morning in America column that
has always must read material on him and
NBC sports.com and pro football talk
compy Kay how are you today I'm fine
when did you talk to dr. pouchy 5:30
Saturday evening there you go so was he
already self quarantined at that point
in time I think he was I didn't hear
about it until we were my wife and I
were watching the news at 6:30 Eastern
and I heard about it then but I was you
know on Saturdays at this time of year
what I basically am doing is trying to
write most if not all of my football
morning in America columns so I'm not
really head down and I'm just writing so
I didn't really know what was happening
in the world at that point so let's get
into it
doctor foul Qi in short I guess said
it's possible that there is an NFL
playing season in 2020 yeah I think he
is bullish on doing everything like he
loves sports he understands baseball he
doesn't love football he's okay with it
but he he understands how important
sports are to America and in particular
at this time of year when there is none
going on that we should really try to do
everything we can to you know at least
be playing the games even if fans can't
go to him so he's he's very bullish on
the NFL doing everything possible to try
to play I mean you know as I have
written and he basically assented to I
mean time is on the
outside as he said I could I asked him
would it be piggish for the NFL to start
using up a monstrous amount of tests
like what I would figure at least they
would need to have a season about
200,000 tests for the league to be able
to have essential personnel and players
tested twice a week for the year it
might be more than 200 but he said yeah
it would be piggish if they did it right
now but there's a very good chance three
months from now when all of these tests
are going to be getting used by the NFL
there's a very good chance that it won't
be piggish then because they're mass
producing tests and as he said shame on
us if we don't you know get that part of
it going we need to do it for society at
large so testing tracing and then I know
you mentioned the other day about Dalton
signing in Dallas it's it's important to
have a backup quarterback should your
starting quarterback test positive for
coronavirus and I was beginning to think
well you know if quarterbacks are around
in a quarterback room and wouldn't
everybody have to self quarantine if
somebody did pass test positive in the
same way that doctor foul Qi is but he
he basically said you can get to the
point where if somebody does test
positive for coronavirus you just remove
him from the team test everybody else
and and off we go to week three on to
Cincinnati because I think I think he
views that one test is going to be an
outlier if everyone else tests negative
but that's why you test more than once a
week because as he says you could have
the virus and not test positive and then
two days later test and you're positive
so let's take the case of one individual
player testing positive I think that is
a good reason why you're even when
you're in a locker room and you're with
a team you're still going to practice
social distancing even where it's been
very very interesting about a half hour
ago I got a call from an NFL general the
integer the second one I've gotten in
the last couple days about
this topic and this general manager
basically told me he was inspired by
what he read from from Falchi today in
my column and said that there is a way
and we all need to basically take the
design that the NFL put into play last
week during the week and I think there
was about 10 pages total in those
documents that Roger Goodell sent out to
the teams in which there is an absolute
explicit design of every team and what
to have to do to put a program in place
and the reason why it's so important is
that you know if you have 53 guys taking
a test on a Saturday night just imagine
if four guys test positive I think the
NFL most likely will do exactly what
fozzy said the NFL the team would
announce hey these four guys tested
positive we're not playing this week and
you know so you think of that you know
and obviously think of the opponent the
next day with the opponent the next day
just say oh well you got for you those
four guys aren't playing the rest of you
guys were sure they're safe
no well you would you be a player
wanting to play a team that in the hours
before the game had four guys test
positive no be like walking into the
White House right now and having 50 guys
walk through the White House every one
of them would look at everybody that
they're meeting and the White House
saying so did you run into the two
people who tested positive and so you
really are going to have two teams are
going to have to play pay painstaking
attention I said that is one GM that as
crazy as this sounds it'll be as
important this year to have a pristine
hygienic plan and and cleaning plan all
through your facility
that'll be as important
having a good offensive and defensive
game plan for that week's game because
if you don't keep it clean there's not
going to be a game Peter King of NBC
Sports here on the Rich Eisen show
another story that popped up on a Friday
night actually and our show kind of got
into the middle of it because we had to
Shawn Watson on and we'll play that
later on this hour a back prior to the
2017 draft saying that he did in fact
speak to the Chicago Bears leading up
but he tweeted out on Friday night that
the Bears never once talked to him and
that's just you know maybe old ancient
news but certainly not in Chicago I mean
this is this is the the stuff that just
lights up a Chicago Bears fan because
the seasons gonna begin with the marquee
matchup between deshaun Watson and
Patrick mahomes think about it you got
those two guys starting an NFL season
and nobody bats an eye over it and as a
matter of fact we're all ready to sit up
and watch that and true Biscay may not
even start week one in Detroit and so
this is quite something Peter I'm
wondering what your reporting was at the
time or anything that you might have
gathered over the weekend you know I
don't know I don't I didn't do anything
this weekend with it rich but I I don't
know whether the Bears had a man or
worked them out I mean obviously I take
Watson at his word but I would that that
would be a huge surprise to me you know
if it's true it just would because I'm I
just it would be a huge surprise to me
and and maybe maybe look this could have
been like remember the time when what
was it mm and I don't even remember what
year it was night whatever but when when
Jay Cutler was the first-round pick in
the Denver Broncos and he was sitting
there at his family party in Indiana or
something like that and he had a bunch
of hats like he may be at 10 hats and he
didn't have a Broncos hat so they never
talked to me once so it's not always
the best indicator yes whether you've
decided to pick a guy or not pick them
if you haven't you know taking a trip
there or whatever but to not spend any
time with the guy is a little bit weird
to me if indeed that's the way it
happened
Peter before I let you go we have fans
call up all the time about Dez Bryant
and certainly since the Packers need a
wide receiver clearly and the Cowboys
went in a different direction with 88
but we're always wondering what about
this this guy what what is going on what
does best you can tell right now you
know I think most people in the NFL
viewed him view him as a retired player
and you know because he hasn't played
now what in a couple of years you know
my gut feeling is people you know that
the Green Bay Packers would rather say
we will let Allen Lazard and equity Mia
st. Brown be our you know sort of our
prospects you know this year for you
know to keep growing with Aaron Rodgers
but you know I don't know I it's been a
long time since I've asked anybody about
deser Brian it's it's a it's interesting
how he just literally fell off the face
of the earth you know that and you know
and I wonder I wonder with a guy like
him whether people might think he'd be
any sort of a distraction or you know if
he doesn't get balls throw to him two
straight weeks would he pop off or
something like that and that I just
don't know but he's certainly a guy I
feel about him the way I feel about
Percy Park it's a weird year because
Percy Harvin now wants to play and he's
been out of the game longer I guess four
full years longer than Brian has but
both of those guys I would bring him to
camp I'd see what they have left
I mean Percy Harvin midway through the
was in 2015 or 16 season was in you know
was probably the Offensive Player of the
Year whatever year he had the incredible
first half of the season for
I would what's the harm doesn't cost
anything to bring those guys into camp
see what they have left I'd certainly do
it before I let you go Peter a large
party or column today about Don Shula
I'll just give you the floor and what
you'd want people to know and I know you
went back and forth on Twitter with a
few jet fans about the AFC Championship
game back in the day where he you know
Don Schiller Don Shula basically for the
last quarter century has been mostly
invisible
you've seen them wave to crowds or
whatever hey and if I was winning as
coach here's Don Shula but think about
it if you're 35 or 40 years old would
you really know anything about Don Shula
you weren't you weren't alive during the
perfect season year no you weren't
you you don't you even less you've
really studied football history you
wouldn't know that in 1965 at the age of
35 that is a head coach because both of
your quarterbacks were injured you had
to go in and play the Green Bay Packers
in Vince Lombardi and Bart Starr with
your running back playing quarterback
and you took the powerhouse Packers to
overtime in that playoff game and then
obviously the only perfect season in the
100 years that the NFL has ever played
he's the coach all the tight games they
played that year just a I mean there's
so much about him and so rich quite
honestly this was you know the New York
Times is all the news that fits the pre
that's fit to print that they really
feel like they're the paper of record
and I know a lot of people in the
country don't feel that way but to me
sometimes I want my column to be the
column of record if you read about the
NFL in this week you're going to read
4,000 words that will tell you who Don
Shula is and until the anthony foul he
called me at 5:30 on Saturday I was
going to have the Don Shula story at the
top of my column and I'm sure have a
bunch of people say what do I want to
worried about that old man for and maybe
wouldn't have even read the car
but that's one of the favorite things
I've ever done in one of these columns
because I really felt like I got 12
stories that really got you to know who
this guy was but thanks for the floor no
you got it Peter and thanks the time I
appreciate it and again the the ultimate
question I'm sure you put the Falchi was
bulge it will see right I mean he can't
give any sort oh I think he feels like I
think we all feel like there's going to
be football in the fall there's a very
good chance that the NFL is going to be
playing games in the fall but there's a
very big but there's going to be a
second wave of this disease do not get
comfortable all those people who are
going to be working on this for NFL
teams you know what it's not it you you
didn't do a great job until the Super
Bowl is over then if the NFL plays a
Super Bowl this year you can say alright
NFL you did a great job in in in
basically conquering the pandemic Peter
thanks for the time really appreciate it
okay Rach take care you take care that's
Peter King here on the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here